movie today it's my perfect aunty likes
to spend a lot of money we got stop that
do you feel different now that you're
seven years old
good morning good morning again when you
going going going everybody it's a very
special day we're I'm very very excited
because it is a my mama told me naomi
was i miss Anthony oh I had someone I
wanted to do today and he said I want to
watch a movie with my cousin Stephanie
and Jeffrey that stuff's me and he
wanted to eat popcorn at the movies and
he won an ice cream cake time to go get
some food where we gonna go get some
breakfast ad birthday boy yes tim
hortons I love Tim Hortons outcome were
you guys too noisy no
zephanie you lost your shoes it's
definitely taller than email yet getting
close do you feel different now that
you're seven years old zephanie swans
tuna and crackers your breakfast maybe
ones tuna crackers for breakfast it's my
birthday we're going to a new game it's
called three things get to say three
things that you're grateful for life
he'll thank you
I mean like
nice Nina's message of the day is
combining we've got a little extra time
before the movie stars so we're going to
go to ikea and let the kids play around
the place center well Nina goes and buy
something
Stephanie's too tall that go on the kids
there yeah yeah now I don't you know
that you're not old man you're an idol
full ten is tennis an idol right we drop
the boys off we're now we're gonna go
find Nina we're gonna find Nina make
sure she doesn't spend too much money
right yeah and she likes to spend a lot
of money we got stuff that okay this is
what you do when you see here you say et
we don't really need that they like no
here we don't really need that right hi
Nina how are you doing we don't really
mean that no he told me to say that she
wants to buy glasses what do we tell her
me know we don't really need that ready
let it get it let her get it Mort oh no
Stephanie no look she got to she got two
packs stephanie is all your fault
I have a giant rain
let's get to the car and go watch
finding dory that's not a lot of
excitement let's go watch finding dory
there we go all right I like that guys
here we are at the theater we made it
guys have any burden to the Haven we're
gonna go in we had some fun and we'll
film as we come in did we enjoy enjoy
all right now we're going to go look for
Hayden's maiden decided that he wanted
to go find his own present so we're in
the mall I'm going to go look for
something for him
it was a store full of toys and hating
him like anything so we're gonna go
check out the lego store knife no luck
in this mall Hayden has decided that he
wants to go to the business which they
don't happen too small so we're gonna
hop in the car and go find all right
here we are at yorkdale hey Tina Nina
had a nice nap in the car on the drive
Haven still a little bit stoned out
super sunny facing day let's go find
hate in his present what did you find
Hayden the man had her we got hated his
birthday present you happy nice alright
now we're going to go head off to see my
parents
and have a birthday lunch three o'clock
lunch / dinner with some presents and
cake yeah
lemans looking around me a new purse
need a new purse we definitely don't
have time to buy a new purse I really
want to get you a new purse what's going
online shopping that's not like top of
my priority today I'm just you know
we're so rushed to any time we're so
rushed right now we have to just really
bad that we can't do it right now I on
the website of thing I wish we had more
time today okay I could buy you like you
don't agree about it that means me right
now website is easy goodbye n shine so
much well I thought meanest you want me
to explain you online what is all mine
what is the internet ago understand
using the name okay how does internet
work and something like a purse so I
feel like you need to look you need to
like feel it you have it in your hands
and try it on and see right then i right
leave a comment am i right pictures by
purse online right I really wish here at
the time today but will prob I do what I
do hey I don't need you to talk about me
come back another time
turn off the TV all right hand up day we
had a good day come on in and just came
out of his ba let's get low everybody
get low did you have a good day yeah you
like being salmon know you have a good
first day of seven now enjoy your
birthday you get enjoy your new toy
you're gonna have a good sleep now
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon bye good night
inside thanks Tony now okay night night
mr. okay